welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike comer just
last weekend the Club hosted by 2015
chess club championship won by none
other than our very own Grandmaster been
Feingold and a couple Webster kids Eric
Rosen and Ashwin Jarrell am all right so
many great games are played and we will
not be watching those instead we got the
lower boards so big round 5 matchup
between Ken West and Matthew Manley the
winner would get $200 all right so Ken
Wes has the white pieces all right and
they don't let me go all right sorry
starts out d4 black counters with d5
Knight f3 Knight f6 now if you've been
watching my lectures you know there's a
move I would not recommend here III it
it's very very bad to box in your Bishop
that early for no considerable reason
okay so well let's see how can West's
Bishop does in this game so now black
decides I'm gonna get my Bishop free of
the my pawn chain and play Bishop to f5
gaining more space so now Ken goes with
the c-4 and black plays c6 the ideas
like Queen to b3 unfortunately do not
work for Ken West in this position
because black could simply defend the
b-pawn with Queen to c7 so not too good
so he just brings out his knight and now
black plays east 6 and notice with this
Bishop on f5 he's doing a lot better
than sin there on c8 all right so now
white decides I'm just gonna bring my
Bishop out to e - so black captures it
Bishop captures back so by taking on a
sea
or with the black pieces what move can
white now get excited about possibly
playing later on the move efore so we'll
see if there's a there's a great time to
strike with E for so Bishop takes c4 now
Bishop to b4 pins the night so he gets
castled
and no longer has to worry about the pin
so black should just castle as soon as
he can
but instead he decides getting this
night off the back row is more important
which is not true so white plays the
move Bishop to d2 and the bishop d2 is a
pretty weak move you want you want your
bishops being more active and attacking
not just on d2 and now black plays Queen
to c7 let's see if we can figure out a
really good move for white here and hint
Ken West doesn't that see it all right
so let's be better than ken west what
move did did we say we really wanted to
get in for white here efore alright but
it looks like you know we only have one
defender of e4 when he's got two so what
would happen if we played efore and we
took it bad things would happen because
then the knight takes the bishop and now
we have this bishop under attack so if
he takes right we'll take and if this
bishop takes the bishop what move do we
play yes
how about how about D D either night
action actually and then we're up a
piece for a point so you got to be
obvious be looking for tactics but
instead kind of West plays the head
scratch or Bishop to e2 okay so so now
the bishop goes to d6 and now he's got
Queen Bishop on the same diagonal that's
called a battery and you usually want
the Queen the more powerful piece going
first
cuz then it could be a potential
checkmate if the knight wasn't there
instead of just a Bishop check all right
so Ken wes is afraid of it so he plays
g3 so black gets castled and uh you know
ken gets his rook going so now black is
going to move some pawns on the Queen
side here so now ken puts his rook on
the same file as the Queen so so what
tactic is Ken threatening right here
Knight takes b5 right because if he
would just make a silly move and the
Knight takes pawn would not be able to
take because bye-bye Queen okay so so
Matthew sees it he defends it with a six
so now Ken decides he's going to put his
bishop back to f1 and get the end shut
okay
so black attacks the night fish up there
alright before actually yeah Bishop
cheat you okay
now the night goes there and now Ken
gets an e4 finally and now his bishop
might be able to play finally and now
what is the big threat with E for here
e5 yes he'll get the the pawn pork so
his opponent you know you can see these
things so he plays a five himself so
that captures captures write attacks the
bishop so captures Queen takes and now
black gets his Knight to c4 attacking
the bishop so it's simple your piece is
attacked move it right okay so he
attacks the bishop again so he captures
it and I can place Queen to f5 so he's
eyeing at h7 hopefully somebody can come
and help him so let's see so moves this
rook to e8 here and attacks the night so
the knight is under attack so so so
Knight d5 is played here forking the
Queen and the bishop and they'll in the
live game and so Knight takes with Chuck
Queen takes Queen takes pawn takes okay
so now in this position who likes white
here or who likes black
so so the material is equal but you know
Black has these double isolated ponds so
so white should be ahead here but why
it's got to deal with one issue right
now what is black attacking right here
if it was black to MU if he can get out
of this tactic good morrow yeah Knight
to d3 so he takes over the D file so
black protects his C pawn tax the knight
Knight retreats Rilke tax the pawn
there's only one way well there's
probably a couple ways to save it so he
attacks there he protects rook takes
rook takes and now the pawn is still
under attack so King protects it broke
up so he attacks or a plays c5 so what
is blacks intentions right now with the
move c5 probably just play C 4 C 3 C 2 C
1 yep so so instead Ken's morn we've got
two sites on this loose pawn so Matthew
decides not to protect the a part and
just go with his plan c4 pawn takes pawn
takes so do you think it's a good idea
for 10 to take this undefended pawn on a
6
yes yeah cuz cuz cuz Matthew is only one
two three moves away from getting a
queen here so you have to address that
situation how would you address this
there's a couple different ways the big
thing is you want this bishop to help
out but unfortunately they don't move
like rooks right so what could we
possibly do yes yeah so this is this is
an idea right
but it's kind of dangerous because if
this night ever somehow gets around to
d3 or a2
we're in a lot of trouble but that might
take them a while but the bottom line is
the other other idea is play e5 and I
try to get your Bishop going here but
after rook takes a 6 there's no hope
that there's no way to stop it the e5 is
just too late because he just ignores
the threat and c2 takes with Chuck so
Matthew's got a coin now and he's
looking pretty good so he wins the
bishop with Chuck and now can anybody
see checkmate here Matthew couldn't find
gold we made off Grandmaster on the case
here pawn h5 mate
okay but unfortunately he wants the
Queen checkmate check still not mate so
now he gets frustrated you can't figure
out the checkmate so he these guys gotta
go win the rock they're gonna figure it
out later
no all right now now maybe he's gonna
figure out the mate here anybody find
the mate here Richards finally got one
yeah work takes h5 like it's nothing
yeah yeah even Matthew manly saw that
one yeah no I said because Kings got no
place to go
all right so that was a good one
and now we got Mario's game Mario needed
to win just to get a share of the under
1200 prize so let's see and get off to
get a little bit of prop to get about
$13 profit all right everybody's playing
a stronger player rate at about 1300
okay Mario's got the white pieces so
let's see how Mario does look at this
beautiful Mario the first three moves
that's how everybody should be playing
and now he plays bent bangle it's a
favorite move one move too late though
but Queen c2 all right mm-hmm
he attacks the Bishop Bishop retreats
and now Mario gets in efore right away
probably too fast but whatever the
bottom line is is Bishop is gonna be
nice oh I should be but token so he
takes e4 good Knight takes Knight takes
d4 Knight takes Queen takes and so Marie
decides all right up take with Chuck
Bishop takes and now Mario I bet you
wish you didn't play your Bishop to e2
but where do you think you should have
played them well where's the only other
place you can move right
now Bishop wares are you gonna get a
pawn if you play Bishop to d3 oh yeah
you're right you want to move your
Bishop to d3 here okay all right but he
chooses e to castles castles Bishop e7
rook attacks the Queen Queen retreats
and now Bishop d3 it's just you're
wasting moves here alright so h6 Bishop
the d2 okay so Bishop d2 you know like
we were saying before isn't the best but
in this position it makes sense if Mario
has a follow up so what is the natural
follow up in this position Mario
alright you're alright so you so in fact
you can win the bishop on d7 in this
position it just takes a couple moves
run a four [ __ ] you've been at least not
yet
so does anybody's can everybody see how
look this Bishop is on d7 unprotected
okay so that's really if you want to win
pieces look at the ones that are
unprotected especially if they're on the
same line of some of your power pieces
right yeah
Bishop c3 attacks the Queen the Queen
has to move or er e5 fine fine or e5 it
doesn't matter and now how do we win the
bishop on d7 Bishop h7 check right you
could have you could have won this game
at 15 moves Mario so instead he
unfortunately played instead of Bishop
the c3 played the move b4 not good
enough not good enough all right
so now he plays Bishop d6 and now none
of the tricks work get this rook over
Bishop e5 Bishop e3 rook over so now
Mario plays rook back to f1 and and so
now his opponent luckily open the C for
the up file for him so now he's
attacking the Queen and can generate
some kind of King side attack possibly
three bishop attacks the rook got to be
really careful well not really but the
bishop and the Queen are both coming
down on g2 here but luckily the Queen is
protecting it so obviously Mario just
plays rook work over attacks the Queen
and our queen retreats all right they
attack the bishop bishop retreats
all right so so it looks like a just a
random move I just moved my queen over 1
square no problem
mari I probably did a really slick huh
all right but what is the obvious threat
here yeah well obviously you see it but
yeah he's threatening checkmate so he's
got to do something about it
b5 okay interference so Bishop attacks
the f1 doesn't do anything about it
efore and unfortunately for was not a
good move because now he's got Queen
takes pawn Chuck and you go into h1 so
Queen offering the Queen trade when
you're up you want to trade Mara is not
having any of it so rook attacks the
Queen Queen back Queen h5 so Queen h5
obviously threatens the move Queen takes
h6 if he plays a silly move and now the
point cannot capture it because it's in
a pin okay but he sees it so he plays
King to h8 which could be dangerous
alright so rook attacks the pawn so so
Mario how many players do you have on f7
here I'll give it to great and how many
defenders does he help
oh so if you have a two-to-one advantage
and you could take something by all
means do it right and steady attacks it
again he protects it again it's still
not enough protectors right you've got
three and he's got two you can still
take it instead you've gotten another
guy on it and so takes the Queen's and
now obviously you Mario just take the
pawn already but instead he attacks the
other pawn so how can black say
the app porn and the Jeep on
simultaneously here by playing the
dreaded f6 okay f6 oh and why is this
not checkmate yes it's not checkmate
yeah the bishop can eat them all right
soso Morial why don't you play this move
and threaten checkmate that would have
been good but alright instead you want
to get your king over Warner Wow alright
but you never know you never know if you
can threaten checkmate just do it all
right so now Mario's got his king go and
now all the bishop and Brooke checkmate
combinations are off the table not yet
hurry so they play a little dance Mario
doesn't want to trade bishops his
opponent wants to try to make him trade
it but Mario's not having it pawn takes
pawn takes and so if Mario would play
rook takes here what move would black
play to get his pawn right back any
ideas what can ya notice this Bishop is
immobile because he's in a pin he's in
an absolute pin so he can play Bishop
takes and the bishop cannot capture back
because he's in a pin so okay so Mario
decides well first things first murder
sighs I'm gonna check you okay so King
goes back and then and then he decides
I'm gonna try to protect my e pawn but
nope rook rook comes down so captures
Bishop captures King up now now he's got
a real threat Bishop takes Bishop so I'm
sure he just trades them off alright so
King the f7 it looks like
and all right move but what does it
allow white to play rook h7 putting the
G pawn in a pin so now black has to play
rook the g8 if he wants to save it she
does and now he eliminates that pawn so
rook attacks the pawn threatening check
is really nothing Mario can do about it
so rook takes Czech throws in another
meaningless Chuck and g6 which allows
Mario to give him a check okay now now
Mario don't spoil it for everybody so
now his King just walked into a mating
net okay all right so we got a very
enthusiastic a gentleman back there once
so so bottom line is we do have to
protect the rook protect me what the
King won't work because of work to a4
check Brooke move the rook back to the
other rook love it okay so now so now
he's looking pretty good well maybe it's
not a mating net but so he's got to stop
this check got a stop but he doesn't so
c6 now check King up one move do we have
let's get everybody involved with the
checks yes
for ship you move the rook down oh you
don't want to move the other Brock down
or else he just goes bye-bye
yes move the pawn up one excellent get
everybody involved and so it doesn't
matter if he goes here or here where is
the checkmate Richard do you want to get
get in on the checkmate here checkmate
he's really gonna find you meet him once
that's a specialty so here is the bottom
board
Robert Beekman against Chess Club a ploy
Lulu okay here we go
Robert Beekman has the white pieces and
Robert Beekman actually even though he
was Owen three if he would win out his
last two games or get a full point by
somehow he might end up sharing the
money with Mario alright so here we go
Knight f3 so so he's got to buckle down
and win this all right d v g3 Bishop g2
d3 all right u6 um so everybody's
playing pretty decent here cept for that
move okay why what is everybody's
obsession with Bishop the d2 okay it's
not good okay and plus if you're gonna
play Bishop to g5 right you've got to be
expecting them to attack you right so
either just take it and say I wasn't
bluffing or or don't go there in the
first place okay
so sorry so Bishop back to d2 the white
gets Castle black plays Bishop d6 does
that really threaten anything not really
because this pawn is heavily protected a
better move might be Bishop to c5 at
least you're you're pinning something
you know pending the F pawn
and because he's played Bishop the d2d
four is not a factor here
all right so Bishop d6 Knight up black
gets castle Rickey 1 preparing efore so
Queen the east set Knight attacks the
bishop so what would you play as black
here would you just say all right well
knights and bishops are worth the same
I'll just let them take and and get
double pawns here would you like that
the answer should be no so you can just
retreat it okay just retreat the bishop
all right and that's what Lulu did so
good efore and now attacks the knight
Knight to b5 so it doesn't want to trade
so plays Bishop to c5 white plays f4 so
now what can we play here f4 oh yeah
attack the knight
all right so so the night is under
attack and obviously he doesn't want to
retreat because of Bishop takes pawn
takes Queen takes well Oh No
yeah if you move up you're in for a
world of hurt because the rook is under
attack
slides it over now where's your knight
gonna go the answer is no where it's
gone okay no he's got no place to go
okay so instead Robert makes a threat
greater or equal to pawn takes Knight
with e5 so they take take should take
back with a knight but she takes back
with the Queen and now she's netted a
pawn out of that so she thought but now
Bishop takes the pawn rook attacks the
bishop if you were playing white here
where would you go with the bishop yes
no back support well you're playing like
a 500 good job okay so she's just
defends and now he's like all right I'll
take it you really don't want to be
trading that Bishop for that night
because your Bishop a really good
defender of the King here but you know
not worried about it
all right so rook attacks the bishop
bishop moves back clean up work over all
right so f5 here trying to break it open
all right so now it's broken open relook
at acts the Queen Queen move so notice
Queen rook Queen okay
so just stuff you got to be aware of
okay
luckily both these queens are defended
we're defending the Queen nice defending
the Queen so so and probably no tactics
can happen but you never know you got to
always be on the watch out for him so
white takes the pawn g6
so now you're probably really tempted to
play Knight takes h6 check but you have
better
what's better than Knight takes h6 Shaq
yes all right
nice try you have an answer 96 I like it
fork the Queen and the rook all right so
Queen moves it takes the 8 how would you
capture this Knight back
it's very important that you get this
answer right because there's two ways to
capture this night what's the what's the
good way to take yeah yeah no work the
hook thing so that's what's actually
played in the game so once again you're
you're holding strong at the 500 level
all right so rook takes rook takes the
Queen uh-oh and now now we have a well
if we're not crushing enough we have you
have a crusher of a move here goodbye
move wait the moving win Queen takes
pawn yeah the only party can take and
then Robert such a gentleman which I
never understand Queen g7 mate not Queen
takes a stir so make it a big scene okay
yes and now we have one final game
actually performed by a national master
so we can see how a national master
plays chess no it's not Claudio it is
mr. Jim McLaughlin playing none other
than John Boyer time Boyer all right and
we'll watch it from McLaughlin's
perspective all right here we go so so
let's see we've been playing like a 500
really well let's see if we can step it
up a notch and play like a 2100 all
right efore so this is called the
Alekhine's defense all right so so a lot
of people want to like oh I'm gonna
attack it I'm gonna attack it again but
let's just let's just not do that lets
just play normal okay so Queen could
attack the knight
you know inside we want to put our
knight on f3 okay all right so pawn
takes Knight takes c6 Bishop e2 all
right why do you think you know a lot of
players might play Bishop you know check
which would be abysmal cuz of c6 Bishop
c4 attacks the knight same thing c6 so
Bishop to e2 where do you think he's got
plans with that Bishop yeah maybe just
the f3 we'll see we'll see if it works
castles castles everybody's safe now
Bishop f3 c6 is played Queen up to e2 so
now Bishop to e6 rook d1 so now he's got
his power pieces on the same file as the
Queen so night that gets in the way so
Knight takes pawn takes Queen c7 so how
do you think white is going to protect
this pawn in this position
and it corresponds with his last move
actually you [ __ ] up the b2 right okay
Bishop fianchetto
so good you're playing more like a 2100
this game that's good
so g3 Knight back attacks the rook so
the knight just gets in the way
Bishop attacks the bishop Knight take
something so rook takes with Chuck rook
takes so rook da so he's challenging the
file so after rook takes Chuck Queen
takes e6 pivotal move here e6
so obviously black he's got some issues
here right he's threatening check the
bishops are all up playing it's got a
little issue here so so now black just
needs to relax and figure this out but
instead he plays a really bad move so my
recommendation would be Bishop f6 some
people might even say f6
but Bishop f6 is pretty pretty nice here
as you'll see you decide to play one of
the worst moves you can play Queen to d6
because now after check King takes
obviously we can now check him again
here what's the only good check we have
here Knight to g5 Chuck and Boyer is in
a lot of trouble all right so now so now
White has a to move combination to win
it and you probably don't have to be
rated 2100 national master to fight
let's hope not all right you got it you
got a suggestion so clean behind the
night yeah no no no you gotta you gotta
you got to think forcing moves here so
does everybody know what a forcing move
is it's like do something and you have
to you pretty much have to make a move
that corresponds with my move I'm
forcing you to do something like a check
is a forcing move because look you have
to go the check another example for you
some rules are captures right I capture
you and you have to capture back all
right Richard
all right Bishop takes Bishop so so
naturally kingship I only have to take
the bishop right Rep okay great
we all agree now can we push the pot
yeah it's so exciting
it's so exactly that's how you need to
play chess and then you bang it like
yeah yeah yeah he's sorry yeah sorry
three moves ago so now if Queen takes
you're in a lot of trouble
night checks and forks the king and the
queen and so that's how Jim McLoughlin
won some money at the club championship
John Boyer did recover from the defeat
as well and uh he got a nice check as
well no no and at this point
McLaughlin slammed it so hard Boyer was
like that's it and he left left the
building
so so that's the club championship the
best and the worst and it was a lot of
fun hopefully everybody can join us next
year for a lot of good tournaments at
the Chess Club